Peters Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight a world exclusive interview with
the president of Ukraine Vladimir
zielinski and his wife the first lady
Elena zelenska
Mr President first lady thank you both
very much indeed for taking this time to
sit down with me I greatly appreciate it
and first certainly thank you for giving
me the honor of moderating your summer
the first ladies and gentlemen it was an
amazing day we'll come to that I want to
ask you first we're five months into the
war into the sixth month now
how are you both doing how are you
coping with this
how are you doing how are you doing
well if I may say so to be honest I have
this feeling as if it were one day that
is why when it was the sick day the
seventh day of War since that day I
really have this feeling that all of
this is one very long day
I don't really see the difference
between five months or six months the
only difference is when we feel that at
the battlefield the situation is
stabilized
or we know that at some points in some
positions we are advancing and I keep
thinking about that
but another point is my family my wife
they have found the format how sometimes
we can have this possibility of seeing
each other
thank you for the interview
this interview is one of the good
opportunities for us to see each other
that is very important for us
as you know we are all human beings and
we have to be strong
sometimes we want to have someone close
to be next to us and that is what you
miss in these moments
a
it is
yes I miss my children I miss my wife it
is impossible to get used to it
everything else you can get used to
um
is this like a TV date
yes thank you for this TV date yes yes
because each day each time when we have
this interview we experience Joy because
we have the chance to see each other
throughout past days past months because
during this periodimir has been living
at his workplace and I'm with children
but we are in another place we were
separated and I can see him only several
times per week in the office but
children do not get to see him very
often of course they they miss it under
such a serious period in their life of
our daughter who graduated from school
she's entering University and today
she's going to take an exam and she's
preparing thoroughly for this even she
really needs her dad to be around to be
able to talk to him and this period of
time and she's entering this adult life
so it's important to make sure that
there's such a smooth transition for her
but unfortunately there's something we
cannot afford and what is supportive
what helps us
you understand that you are not alone
all of the Ukrainian people are in this
situation too many are separated and all
of us are waiting for our Victory and
waiting for normal life to be reunited
again and just to lead normal lives like
Ordinary People live
the only thing that I could add here is
that I absolutely agree with Elena I
think that for those people who are in
occupied territories it's much more
difficult and this is something one
cannot get used to actually
so we have to try our best to make sure
we can deoccupy these territories and at
least to save the lives of these people
and to make sure that there is still
hope for them
these kind of situations they can make
or break your marriage is your marriage
stronger do you think because of what
you've gone through in the last few
months what do you think I should I have
to begin to answer
okay okay
I agree with the theory that marriage
gets stronger with challenges and I
think in our case it would be the same
we have become more interested in each
other I think in our case it will be the
same story
we have got something else to say to
each other
that is why I want this challenge to
make us more united
what do you think about it my answer
wouldn't be different
you should have your own opinion about
it of course I have my own opinions and
when you're next to me your opinion has
priority but I'm interested to hear what
you have to say
yeah well what I can say is that I
didn't have any other experience
actually
because I have only one wife and I'm
happy yes that's the right answer it is
yes
you see I am happy to have this set up I
am happy that in my life I have got one
wife one love and one family yeah
I never got any feeling that there was
anything wrong with us or in our
relationship
and I probably well it is how it is
probably there are different moments in
families and marriages and different
points
or maybe do you feel unhappy with me
sometimes not with you but without you
I'm very unhappy yes yes right
[Music]
that is why I can't notice any big
changes the war is making our
relationship stronger
what is so nice I think is you your
relationship was founded on humor
commonly you wrote comedy scripts you
were writing and Performing and I was
going to ask you later in the interview
if you'd had any chance to even laugh
together and then here you are laughing
together and it's very nice to see that
because that's how you met and fell in
love was making each other love it's
true there are no moments of laughing in
our these days or days it's true and and
I and sometimes we I I can see smile and
and also I I have this minutes for
smiling I think it helps helps very much
is it true I've got a question for you
Mr President yes is it true you met at
high school you were high school
sweetheart
is it true you got together with two
friends male friends and all of you
propose marriage to your wife and to two
other women at the same time
is true it was yes I don't remember
exactly why we did such way if you
remember could you please tell a story
yes they had very many very many
performances then and we were always on
the road sometimes it was with them and
their girlfriends were also with them
and when we saw that we had more
flexible schedule for the upcoming
months then the guys decided to put it
to good use because we plan to get
married anyway I remember you three guys
saying let's do it and everything will
be okay and we agreed
let's let's do the right thing and we
agreed somehow you know we agreed yes I
remember we were having a wedding
ceremony every week yes
it was every
every hours is on the 6th of September
and then another couple on the 13th of
September so each Saturday we would have
another function to celebrate it yes
that shows that at the time I didn't
have many friends but if I had 10 or 20
friends we would have had weddings all
over the year who knows
it's a lovely story and you've all got
married within the same 2 two-week
period right yes all three marriages
amazing Mr President
well the most important thing is not to
have divorces every week that we are
managing we are managing yes we are
managing is not the right word and the
problem we are in love with each other
okay okay
Mr President
started that awful night back in
February you appeared very soon
afterwards and made a video address
which you put out on social media and I
remember watching it in real time and
being removed by it and it was really
your decision to stay here in Ukraine
and to encourage the people of Ukraine
to fight for their country some leaders
might have left what made you stay
well it couldn't have gone any other way
because the president is a leader of its
people
the people voted for me and the
strengths of our state
this is something that I have already
mentioned the strength of our state
this is consolidation
this is unity of our people all of us
together the government the people the
servicemen people just want it started
they would go to the streets they would
stop tanks other military vehicles so
the government had to stay in the center
of the decision-making processes
it was very important to make sure that
there is no informational chaos because
we cannot say that this intimidation
works because otherwise they would say
that their informational propaganda
actually won that the government would
leave this is what they wanted
is chaos because chaos is the weakness
of the state
this is the weakness of Institutions so
one can occupy some territory very
quickly
frankly yes
unfortunately in some places some
settlements or towns of Ukraine this is
what happened
with some police officers some local
authorities yes they would they would
actually run away and it was possible
for the troops to address sooner but
actually there was a lot of resistance
and it was next to impossible to occupy
because of the resistance coming from
people
this is why we really tried really hard
to make sure that other territories
remain integral that was the only way
for me to act
and I understood the consequences and I
think that these consequences they were
so much more important than what happens
to me the next day
first lady that night you had to wake
your children and tell them this Ward
started your children at 18 and nine
years old that must have been a very
difficult thing to do and then you had
to leave your husband as you went to
lead the country and you had to leave
him perhaps
fearing I don't know you tell me that
you may never see him again
yes it was
it wasn't it I was a little bit worried
actually when I had to wake up the
children to let them know that the war
had begun and that we had to park some
stuff but luckily I didn't have to do
that because when I entered the room of
my daughter and she was already awake
and she understood everything because
you know social media everything works
so fast these days I didn't see in her
eyes any panic
she just asked me
what do we have to do now and that was
exactly the same question which I
addressed to my husband
and what he told me was wait wait and I
will tell you
had some thoughts
would it be possible for me to see him
again how long is going to last what
happens next the fear was there but I
try not to show it to the children that
I was confused that I was scared and I
was not really scared but it was
important for me to be in a cheerful
mood to keep talking to them to smile to
them that is what I had to do and after
this very long day believe me my cheeks
hurt because I had to smile so much and
to be cheerful
and there's volodimer just said as for
any Ukrainian the 21st of February keeps
repeating every day
you know this is the 24th of February is
a permanent condition in which we are
living right now as the circumstances
are changing but we're just waiting for
one thing when all of that is going to
be all rolled back and we will be back
to our normal lives that is why I don't
I wouldn't really want anyone in the
whole world to endure these horrific
days that we had to go through at the
end of February yes but we hope for
better
absolutely absolutely we are sure about
our future we believe in peace we
believe in our Victory
and I absolutely agree well this is the
way it is we are living in these times
social media they work faster they
explain things faster than parents do
sometimes and we can say that it's not
only about our children we have children
of War they hear a lot about what's
happening they understand that these war
made them more grown up and there are
very many important things which have to
be explained by parents
your son your son I believe he now wants
to be a soldier yes he wants how do you
feel about that
yeah
I'm proud of that
I am proud of our army and as a father I
would be proud if my son became a
soldier I can provide support for him
I know he is wearing military style
clothing he's got quite a lot of weapons
not the kind of weapons we've got from
our partners
you've become
he's ready to protect his mother and our
family it must be strange for your
children because you've become this this
International hero to many people
incredibly famous the whole world knows
of you and is inspired by you and yet to
your children you're just your dad and
you they see you on television I presume
and it's still it's their father not
this Global I hope I still father yeah
but have you seen them at all
yes at some point there was the movement
of my family to different places it was
important in terms of security of my
family
it was not possible for us to
communicate or to use any means of
communication for some longer periods of
time
at some point it was possible for us to
have an online date and I saw my
children
and
it is such a delight because this is
what it gets you through this is what I
can hear first lady
the world sees your husband as a hero is
he your hero
yeah maybe you want to answer without me
yes I think it would be better I think
that I have already answered similar
questions a couple of times already and
if each time I have to answer this
question because of Victory is getting
closer and closer you know I cannot make
up any other answer
there's only one truth
I have always known that he's the most
trustworthy person ever and under this
condition this is something the world
learned
and the same is true about our children
he has always been a champion for them
the best dad the best person in our
family and right now they're not really
surprised they take it as a test they
have this confidence and they support
I'm one of the best ones in our family
yes
yes in our family
but there's not many
president having having spent time with
having spent time with the first lady of
the summit all day are you familiar with
the phrase punching above your weight
are you familiar with that phrase
it means you're doing you're very lucky
you're doing very well yeah yeah I think
so
I'm very lucky with my wife
I got really lucky to have her as a wife
with my family with my children
I think that I'm a happy person I am
absolutely a happy person you've said on
a more serious note that the Russians
you're the number one target for them
and your family is the number two target
that must be a constant pressure for all
of you
it's not really about you thinking about
your family yes in this case the family
is at the center of attention and yes
this is true
these targets still remain for some
people from the Russian Federation
as far as I am concerned I think it is a
given I think that it is a part of this
situation we are in and we are in a
state of War
I think that's any person can become a
Target
there is an example there is a good
example of the number of artillery
missiles and some other strikes which
took place
innocent people suffer civilians suffer
our soldiers and me if I can really put
it this way
we are at War we were at War yes we
understand that these things could
happen the result could be a bad one
some people lose their lives
but what about suffering of civilians
their families
common people
and the only thing they did was being a
Ukrainian
because this is what it is for Ukrainian
soldiers and politicians politics
that is why I think this is something
which is unsettling
and first lady for you as a mother
to know the Russians are targeting not
just your husband as president but you
and your potentially your children your
family
for any mother that that must be a
terrifying thought
foreign I tried never to think about
this numbers of targets because when you
think in terms of Target number one
target number two
if you think too much into it then you
can become really paranoid and yes I
understand I'm a mother like many other
models in Ukraine that is why all
ukrainians are Targets number two and of
course it's an unpleasant feeling I
don't want to think that they want to do
this to our family I'm trying to push
this kind of thoughts away I can see
that you can see what they did to
civilians and what they're doing now in
any part of our country I don't
understand what they've got in mind and
possibly we are in danger I don't want
to allow this kind of thought to go deep
into my mind because I could feel scared
and this is not what we need right now
Mr President the Hungarian prime
minister Victor Orban said that you
can't win this war but Russia is too
dominant the sanctions aren't working
and that eventually America will have to
do a deal with Russia to end this what
is your response to that
the war of Russia against Ukraine is in
our territory the United States of
America or our partners and Russia
unfortunately is an Invader and an enemy
that is why the partner and an enemy
cannot really make a deal about the
future of our country the country which
is fighting for its independence and for
its sovereignty nothing is going to
happen without our participation
regardless of what Russia think
what is important to us is that our
partners understand this the United
States of America in particular
if you're talking about those statements
of the Hungarian prime minister
sometimes we say something when it seems
to us so
and sometimes we say what we want to say
when we want this to be this way
we say this but sometimes you know these
answers you know we fight on the ground
we fight in the air
it is easier for us to see what the
future holds for us this is why we want
to talk about the sanctions the biggest
problem is that Russia does not
understand the outcomes of what it has
already done he does not understand the
consequences of these sanctions because
one of these outcomes is the actual
introduction of these sanctions the
isolation of the president and the
military that is why it is such a blow
to their development and primarily it is
the isolation of the people this is what
has happened and it has already happened
another point is no one knows about the
consequences of these sanctions from the
economic Viewpoint we understand that
Russia is going to lose a lot
technologically
the West I think they will stop really
being involved in Russian economy or
when it is trying to find balance
between Russia and Ukraine this is what
he's trying to do he's an exceptionist I
will say that he is an exception when it
comes to the European Union it's the
problem that at the moment Putin and
Russia are effectively blackmailing the
world over food supply over energy
Supply that maybe the world has been too
reliant on that supply and now Putin can
use that to effectively paralyze the
world is that a problem
the world was weak and was very
diplomatic when talking about their
attitude towards the Russian Federation
because the world in its principles is
always divided the management of the
country
and the people
and it kept saying that it's very
important to show some way out for their
people
that's we cannot really impose sanctions
on everyone because most people they are
innocent
they have nothing to do about what is
happening and what the Russian
government decided when talking about
the occupation and full-on Invasion
later the world understood that no well
people of Russia they are guilty of
keeping the silence well not everyone is
silent you can hear some voices but
unfortunately this is something that is
not very common
so if you give this possibility to kill
other people then you're not just
Witnesses
that is why we need to do everything
possible for your government
for those people whom you voted for
every four five or six years I think
because they changed the Constitution
then it is something that you're guilty
of will you will you ever contemplate
doing any kind of deal which involves
Ukraine giving up territory to Russia
Henry Kissinger and others you know have
suggested you should go back to the
start of the war and give up the
territory which Russia had before that
point do you accept that or do you think
he's wrong
we
know minion we are not prepared to
exchange or trade the territory of the
independent state of Ukraine
we have no right for this first of all
we are the government because this land
belongs to Ukrainian people then the
second thing is is that I don't truly
understand these compromises or talks
with Russia in the format in which it
was suggested by the Russian side
and it was an ultimatum for us and we
know that ultimatums
this is not a dialect this is not about
diplomacy or talks and we know it from
our experience that ultimatums with
Ukraine this is something which will not
work which is not working and you know
that we have already have the past
history of having so many ultimatums for
from them throughout the history of our
state
that is why for three years I've been
suggesting this dialogue to the Russian
side to find a diplomatic solution to
this armed conflict to the war
when before it became a full-scale war
but right now believe me they don't want
peace
they're not ready to have a dialogue
what they say for the media and what
they are doing these absolutely
different stories what your people have
been saying to me I interviewed a father
in butcher whose son was tortured and
murdered by the Russians and he was very
emotional and when I suggested to him
how would you feel if your president did
a deal with Russia he said no no no no
no and I interviewed two young women
whose apartment block was the last
apartment block to be to be hit by a
cruise missile a month ago the same
reaction instant No Deal they hate yes
they hate and it's understandable when
you when they when so many families lost
for example their neighbors their
children
what the deal
so what the result of this deal
could Russia or can Russia give a child
back no that's why they say no
so there are no emotions only one
emotion hate yes
first lady I remember your husband going
to Butcher and the emotion and fury on
his face I know you felt the same about
this and you've talked about how the
civilization and then there's what's
going on here and the Russians are
behaving in a way that you just never
imagined possible a total lack of
humanity
tell me about that
no
um
any civilized person during this war
would have terrible feelings
fear and hate towards the enemy
try to explain it to come on English
any civilized person during this war
would have terrible feelings fear and
hate towards the enemy and we tried to
explain it to Common Englishmen when
they take their child to bed try to
imagine what is going to happen at night
if there are the sirens
and explosions next to where they live
what would they grab from their
children's bedroom and where would they
run to if they recognized there's
already a large queue of cars trying to
leave the city are they going to take
their pets with them and imagine if you
stayed there and you earned the
occupation
imagine the road you usually take your
child to school with tanks on it
um
the grave of your close relative in your
back Garden because you can't have a
normal funeral to remember them normally
and imagine you have to search for water
and you only source is a dirty puddle
like it was a mariopul
the medical service is not available
just imagine you are in your home and in
two hours time you are forced to deal
with these kinds of problems just to
survive you don't understand why this is
happening what is your view of Vladimir
Putin the man who is leading this war
it is difficult to put it into words
it's not possible to understand how one
crooked idea can throw the whole of
mankind into the Medieval ages
I really don't have words and I really
don't want to say anything aloud
because
Normal words don't exist to describe
this
Mr President he is your enemy in this
war he's the leader of Russia they've
been doing despicable things to your
people bombing maternity hospitals
committing war crimes no question
torturing people murdering them what is
your view your opinion of vadimir Putin
yeah
well it's clear and as you have
mentioned he is Enemy Number One in this
war
it seems to me the scariest thing about
it is that he is in fact sane and he
understands what he's doing I'd say
that's the scariest conclusion I can
make that he understands what he's doing
he knows how many people he kills
he knows how many people were raped and
by who
and the number of children killed or
deported
therefore
I only understand one thing
the world allowed the situation to
develop
it allowed such a person to emerge
with that ideology and attitude towards
people
the world should understand that this
result this mistake to allow this
situation is the responsibility of the
whole world to give the possibility for
this to happen it is not about democracy
I wouldn't want to mix these things
because some leaders say that what did
we have to do it it is not really about
democracy do you believe do you believe
you can win this war
yes no question yeah yeah
I don't only believe it I know it will
happen
we will win
we already showed the whole world that
he can kill us
but to conquer our people is impossible
millions of soldiers have died but he
cannot occupy the people how important
how important
he can occupy these towns and Villages
but all of them would be destroyed
because without ruining them they will
not be able to take those places
how important has it been to get support
from so much of the world for Ukraine
this is the nature this is the goal
number two like you said there is the
aim number one number two
but there are also the goals of Ukraine
our goals Is Our Land
that's number one
both number one and number two This Is
Our Land and our people
how we can get it we need some help
and nowadays it's very important
but number two is of course the union of
our country
trends of the country and it leads to
the help from like an ambulance they
help from the world nine one one from
the whole world
and exactly right now we need this
powerful help how important has Boris
Johnson the British prime minister been
to deport
um we really needed the attitude and the
relationship between the leaders
we have been in contact every other day
I was not only connected through the
bureaucratic way I was able to call him
once a day every other day
when the situation became easier after
the occupation occasionally they have
been in contact lately not like having a
conversation once a month for once every
six months these shows we have such a
close relationship
are you worried that Boris Johnson is
now going to be leaving Downing Street
leaving
to be honest I am worried about it you
ask me do I worry yes I worry a lot we
would like to have at least the same
level of support because my personal
relationship with Boris accelerated the
level of British support that was
provided
the British were the leaders in this
kind of support I know that any person
any candidate who will take this
position
they will help Ukraine in the same way
like Boris but I'm worried yeah I'm
really worried because we need to have
at least the same level not worse
because our personal relationships
they influence the help how fast we got
the help from great representative his
last words to the British Parliament as
prime minister was
baby which of course comes from
Terminator and the next line is I'll be
back there's already a campaign
to have Boris Johnson back as prime
minister would you support that
not only is
I have no right to play in politics
what I can say is he is a big friend of
Ukraine I want him to be somewhere in
politics in a position to be someone I
don't want you to disappear but the
decision is in the hands of the British
people
and the two candidates to be the next
prime minister Rishi sunak and Liz Truss
what is your message to them
one of them will be prime minister
within a few weeks
I would be happy to cooperate very
closely like we used to have with Boris
the same close relationship with the UK
and Ukraine
I know those two candidates are very
respectful
and they have the support of the people
and the society from the UK
do we know about this support
we know about the positive strength of
these leaders
I used to have contact with least trust
we would be happy to cooperate with
whoever is elected as Leaders
whoever is the leader at the highest
level of support will be provided from
the Ukraine
what about America hugely important
they've given billions of dollars to
help your effort but President Biden
hasn't been to Ukraine yet would you
like him to come very much
everyone sees Ukraine's attitude towards
the U.S this would be the highest
and we had huge support from the First
Lady
she met with olena and it was the
correct visit
very I would say unexpected I would say
we were waiting for it a lot but we
didn't expect it to happen
these are very important things
so then I will not say it for herself I
can say it
that was a very important moment she did
a great job and her efforts really
worked there are quick decisions from
the Congress and the White House that
emerged after her speech and her visit
and these are very important things and
of course the visit of Biden Abu
President Biden to Ukraine would be the
strongest signal which can be given in
support of Ukraine have you invited it
yes you have yeah are you hopeful he'll
come
I don't know that his choice I mean not
not even here his choice that is of his
security I mean that that choice I think
if you will have any possibilities he
will come is there more America could be
doing right now that's so powerful
obviously as a country yeah president as
the president of a country that is in
the war
I can tell you that the health would not
be sufficient until the war is over and
until we win
so you understand the US Presidential by
then a few times I've spoken with
President Biden and I told him about our
people and about our country I said
forgive me if I'm quite firm in my
position maybe some things are not very
diplomatic but he gave me quite a
dignified response that he understands
and he would do the same in my place he
would do the same thing can I talk to
you about morality with the position of
the West here because if you were a NATO
country
then NATO would have attacked Russia but
because you're not a NATO country
they will supply arms for you to do the
fighting but NATO won't engage directly
and yet NATO is the biggest military
force in the history of the planet Putin
is using his nuclear weapons as a
protective shield to allow him to commit
these atrocities is there going to be a
moment in this war when NATO should feel
a moral duty to intervene more directly
up isn't it
still creative
it has been so many times I've had a
conversation with many different leaders
about NATO and their role
they didn't take part on time
and what kind of consequences did they
have of it
first of all I guess that if Ukraine
were in NATO
I'm not sure that the president of
Russia would be the one who is right now
there
that's the strongest weakness for them
and that's the strongest victory of the
western world
the second I guess that NATO will be
involved and in a diplomatical way it is
already there
because Russia will hear the message
they say that NATO is fighting against
us because Russia will never ever be
able to leave who's the fact that
Ukraine that is the country that is 28
times smaller than Russia
their army and government that they are
fighting for their freedom
Ukraine is fighting for freedom and no
kind of things of occupation in three
days nothing worked in this case not
Ukraine is fighting with us NATO is
working with us they say in Russia that
is why this way or other way we
understand that the main enemy for
Russia is NATO you would like to see
Ukraine become a member of NATO and of
the European Union as fast as possible
yes
yes
this is so
I believe there is nothing to fear here
nothing to fear Ukraine deserves to be a
member of NATO with their powers and
strength I guess that would be the
strongest protection but for now NATO
doesn't see us here NATO can see us as
an alliance so they don't see us that's
why now we need some signs of protection
I count I rely on Great Britain America
that they will be the engine and we will
get the security they're all people in
America uh some on the Republican side
in particular who think that America
shouldn't be spending all this money on
a wall here which has nothing to do with
them they think there are more important
things in America like inflation and so
on that they should be working on what
is your message to those Americans who
do not think Americans should be as
heavily involved
we are fighting for absolutely communal
values that our University understood
some time ago I responded that war
doesn't have a distance and the war in
Ukraine is still the war against those
values that are professed in the United
States and in Europe
the distance doesn't exist today
a Russian Rockets can fly over a few
thousand kilometers and tomorrow they
will have rockets that can cover tens of
thousands of kilometers what difference
does it make they kill civilians who do
not agree with the politics of the
president of Russia so this war here and
now in Ukraine and forgive me I'm saying
it's so cynically it's for the safety of
Europe as long as we are resisting the
Integrity of the United States will
continue
therefore we are giving our lives for
your value and the joint security of the
world
therefore the inflation is nothing
is nothing ask those people who lost
their children their peace their
property at the beginning of the
full-scale Russian invasion who is
thinking about masks who is thinking
about inflation these things are
secondary the most important thing is to
survive and preserve your life family
and your country therefore at the moment
we are doing this job but the West has
to help us the other argument that you
will hear and I'm sure you've heard it
is that Putin has all these nuclear
weapons no one should do anything to
trigger world war three what do you say
yeah
I think that if he decides to use it
then there will be no reason for that
explicit reason is only about his
decision their ambitious plans just
listen to me in any other case What If
tomorrow he says you know what Germany I
think that half of there was this
division in the country after the second
world war and I think that that part of
Germany belongs to us
I think that we should have some
influence upon the territory and our
troops should be there
any other case I decided to have a
nuclear weapons
raise our hands do this I don't believe
this this is the choice Europe and the
USA I think we should not really believe
in that do you believe he would ever use
a nuclear weapon Putin yeah I don't know
I don't know I don't know what his aims
are I don't know what the Civilized
World allows him to do because if it
shows its weakness he will use
everything
you mentioned Germany Mr President one
of the more sickening things that Putin
has said is that he's liberating
Ukrainian people from Nazis my
implication you you're a Jewish man you
had relatives who were murdered by the
Nazis that must have been for you a
particularly egregious insult
it's not that it is unpleasant to hear
it you know this is I don't pay
attention to that these are empty words
if something is very populous for their
people I pay no attention to this
if you want to draw attention to these
questions
then the first you need to think about
their first actions and the results of
what they're doing they are Nazis and
take a look at biography and the people
who are close to Putin his family what
happened to them during the times when
the Nazis were out there during the
second World War what was happening who
did he get to lose and for him to take a
look at my family what is their blood
where are they now
and why I don't truly have a big family
I mean people who are still here by the
way tortured by Nazis what happened to
his family were they under occupation or
they were not
so what was happening so I would
probably pay attention to that it's not
really about him I think that political
leaders of the Russian Federation I will
pay more attention to their families is
of the utmost importance President Biden
said that Putin should be removed from
office
do you agree
I think that any war ends with when we
talk about diplomatic Solutions and the
impression that I have is that the
result of this diplomacy is the
conversations between the Ukrainian part
with the presence of our partners and
the Russian Federation
I think that this is the only model
to talk with with someone else not the
Contemporary leader of the Russian
Federation I want to take you back to a
few years ago when you were a comedy
performer in a hugely popular TV show in
which you played an anti-establishment
figure
who runs for president and becomes
president
and then you actually run for president
in real life and you become president
it's a bit crazy when you say it like
that the question is that for many
people it was surreal that you were
playing a role in a comedy show as
someone who becomes president and then
you become the real president
well it is a reality this is the reality
in which we're all living now to be
honest I am proud of the fact that this
is how it happened I'm proud of being
the president of Ukraine that people
voted for me it is a reality and about
this surreal thing I think it's more
about what is actually happening with
our neighbors
for very many years we they lived
alongside and then they decided to
attack us and to kill us
I think it is way more surreal than this
first lady is it true that he didn't
tell you that he was going to run for
president
say true
well he forgot
he forgot
I forgot to tell your wife you're
running for president
he understood that probably I wouldn't
have been fond of this idea and that it
would take a couple of hours of very
difficult negotiations with me that is
why probably each day he was thinking
that this is the day that this is the
moment I should tell her you know but he
kept postponing it then it was on TV I
saw his new year's address it was New
Year's night and found out he was
actually running
wait a minute
you found out on TV
Mr President I'm really you announced it
on television before you told your wife
[Music]
I was not laughing so much so loud
yes he was sitting next to me
there was a long time
10 minutes but that wasn't it okay say
everything okay this question was up in
the air there were some discussions but
it didn't really want to do to keep
asking him you are going to tell them is
it happening is it not somehow I believe
that at that point he will tell me but I
didn't really think that that would be
the moment you have to explain yourself
yes I mean I've heard of not telling
your wife things but not telling you
you're going to be present it's like
crazy
what were you thinking
a difficult decision for our family
I knew that it would hit that yeah
it would be a tough call it's not a joke
or serious matters
it's true that we didn't talk about it
for a long period of time
well then I had been talking about it
separately no that's true we've been
putting off talking about it and
avoiding it for a long time because my
family was not prepared to let me go
you are right my first public statement
that was before the day of New Year
I mentioned that I am intending to run
to the office
it is true that was the moment when
Elena heard about that okay
and she told me that she didn't want
that but the decision
this is your opportunity to apologize to
your wife okay
[Laughter]
well that is my that you know
why not
later do it later when you apologize
again
you were written off at the start of
this war by the New York Times called
you an in-app leader unsuitable for war
another headline this comedian turned
president is in seriously over his head
they couldn't have been more wrong
you've turned out to be the right man at
the right time for your country you've
been an incredibly inspiring leader in
this war
what do you say to those who doubted you
what can I say I'm happy that right now
they can see how wrong they were and
that they admitted firstly do you feel
that Ukraine is fortunate to have your
husband
leading the country at this time
well I think on
country
I cannot really say but this is how I
feel it and yes this is what I can say
on behalf of everyone that we believe in
him and this is the way people feel I'm
not only his wife I also a citizen of
this country and I like this president
laughs
at this Summit which was magnificent
your first lady and first gentleman
Summit which I was proud to help
moderate for you
um there was a moment when I revealed
that my football team Arsenal have
signed a Ukrainian player
Alexander zinchenko I'm very excited
about this it's just happened and I
asked the audience are there any Arsenal
fans in the room and you put your hand
up you're an [ __ ]
yes I think that zigo is the person who
is loved by everyone in Ukraine he is
one of the most recent Heroes of the
nation and ukrainians they always
fervently support football players and
xinjinco is such a nice guy and even
girls like him so much this is why I'm
hopeful when the engine starts playing
our people will become fans of this
football team
foreign
Mr President are you are you an Arsenal
supporter yeah maybe there's some other
footballers that you like let me explain
I know some of them personally let me
explain why you should be because
Arsenal is named after a weapons Factory
which used to make weapons for the
British Army and the Royal Navy
and our motto the motto of the club is
in Latin Victoria
Concordia chriskit which stands for
victory through Harmony
it's appropriate
honestly we are all fans of zinchenko as
olena has mentioned
personally I know very many great
Ukrainian football players so to be
honest they are doing a great thing they
are working really hard they're
well-known people and they're helping us
a lot
will stop talking to me and then I can
do the opposite thing
there are so many of them believe me
there are some legendary figures they
took arms and they are on the front line
and we know some football players from
other teams from Dynamo so I mean that
I'm a fan of football like any man in
Ukraine we've now established thanks to
the first lady you're all Arsenal
supporters and I actually have a gift
for you which I will give you after the
interview of Arsenal shirts for the
president for the first lady and for
both of your children because we need
your support as we'll give you our
support
um thank you both very much indeed for
all the time that you've given me today
I think I speak on everyone's behalf in
the United Kingdom when I salute you for
the courage that you've shown the
inspiration you've shown the people here
we're all behind you
we need you to win this war we
understand the world needs you to win
this war
keep fighting and I think the words I
need to use are Slava Ukrainian glory to
the heroes thank you very much thank you
so that's it from tonight from Kiev
Ukraine where I've just finished this
remarkable interview with two remarkable
people I feel honored and privileged to
be here and I think Ukrainian people are
in great hands
[Music]